Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to the Impossible Quiz Book: Chapter 2.
You all know the drill by now, so I don't even need to explain anything. Let's just get into it! Yay!
Alright, so I got my brain in maximum derp mode, so let's just try to get through this without losing our minds! Which is an impossibility..
How many bits in a byte? none, 1, 255, or depends on the size of your mouth. Well those are all wrong! clicks correct answer Hey!
Hi-score... what? You win, hello score, whisk, lol 69. clicks correct answer and laughs Yeah!
I'm in it, I'm in it! I got the right thing going on!
How do you load a zx spla... oh my god. I don't know what that is... but I know what botulism is, and it's probably not that.
How do you load a zx slapptrum? Load... Oh I did it!
I don't even know... click the, oh my god, no there's too many dots! strange noises
You're really gonna start off with... AHHH dots dots! Oh I saw the dot! Awww... you son of a bitch!
Dot, dot, dot, that's a dot, that's a dot, dot also, dot, dot, dot, dot... Woah! I thought there were dots in the bomb.
Define Earth. Moist and wet and tight! Uh... moist! incorrect Ah shit!
Nope! Define Earth! OK... why is it mostly harmless!? Define Earth!? Oh ok...
What is this? The enemy, a power up, you or all of the above? I don't know what that is! It's a square, it's a dot, it's a block, it's that, it's... oh.
The enemy! Shit! Grrrr! What?? It's that, it's that over there, that's what that is!
It's the dot on the 56, it's the square by your name! clicks correct answer Wait, why is it all of the above!?
Which of these is harmful to hedgehogs? Crab meat, cat food, milk or Bhajis?
Is this actually real, are hedgehogs actually allergic to one of these things? Is this actually what we're doing?
Which of these is harmful to hedgehogs? Why would they be harmful to hedgehogs?
Milk? Ahhhhh! I didn't mean it!
I know in the last game there was a Sonic reference... were cats an enemy in Sonic?
Were crabs an enemy in Sonic? clicks correct answer Maybe? I have no idea!
How do you win an extra guy? Press Tab. presses Tab and fails; angry noises
How do you win an extra guy? Remove the cartridge and blow in it... clicks Oh, apparently not!
What!? Flan!? Oh I thought that was going to be a win!
What!? How DO you win an extra guy?? I would like to know that because I seem to be running out of lives very quickly.
Ok! strange noises Flan? Shhhhiiirrrr... I think I need to click the 10th "flan"
No? No! NO! What do you want from me!? How do you win an extra guy?
Um, extra guy... dude man... uh guy who's running around. Mario... um...
AH! I don't know what they want from me. Wait, am I supposed to use one of these other things?
No... no! What is this? boat horn noise What does that mean? AH I wasted it!
strange noises How do you win an extra guy?
OH! I was here for like 5 minutes on that one! Oh, you son of a bitch!
I really do have to think outside of the freakin' box! If you're gonna be such an ass...
Ok, this is a snake... What am I...? What am I doing? Woah, there are no instructions!
I seem to be lost! AH! AHHH!! Why??
How am I supposed to know which one of these to press? AH! AH!
Oh god! How am I gonna do this?? I don't know!
AH! counts to square 59 OH! Wait no, It's time for Phlovopong?
What is Phlovopong? What are you talking about? Did I... I mean I did it... I... I... ok nevermind.
Oh god! No! I was terrible at Pong...
I'm not skipping this one, son. You mean I gotta sit here and play Pong!?
You're such an ass! Why do I have to play Pong?? You are such an asshole!
Die you bastard! Thank you. Oh "bastud"... new firmware? Oh no.
This is... this is a trick! AH! NO! Press 's' to skip. Skip what??
5... What happened?? What shall we play? I quite fancy a game of strip poker.
Oh.. well if you had only said so, I'd be... no.
Fast forward won't let you skip this part, you utter ballbag. Well how bout you go fuck yourself! That was an option too!
Oh.. oh! I don't know if you guys can see that, but I just remembered in the beginning there was a question that said 'load " "'... no, play.
gasp It worked! Ah it worked! Oh...
What is that? What is... oh... ah! Why is it so messed up?
How many colors in the spectrum? Um, shit, purple, eeeaaa-orange color, triangular red, orange, and marmalade.
So that's 8 colors. Ah! These are all wrong! No, no... no! clicks correct answer WHY??
How do I kick arse? Bap, bip, bap, bloody butt, bloody butt, bloody... oh!
How do you get rid of the red ring of death?
I don't know, buy a PS3? AH! There's a cream for that. AH! It takes so long to get back! Shiiiaatt.
This is what I think of your game!
I don't know! Get rid of the red ring... Oh no! no... OH!!!
Boof boof boof boof boof boof! I know it has something to do with that red ring!
How do I get rid of it? What do I press? Oh... gasp I just upped it away! Yay!
What is the first book of the Bible called in Europe and Japan?
I don't know! Good morning, Mr. Christ! I don't know! AH!
AH! Knobs and Knockers... the Mega Drive!? Really??
What is the name of the prequel to Metal Gear Solid? laughs at Metal Gear Flaccid OH!
Which planet is furthest from the Sun? Uh, well I don't know. What are you talking about?
Planet in our... OH NO! I didn't know there was a bomb!
Ok, so Pluto is not a planet anymore, so it's gotta be Neptune... yeah there we go. That one was actually logical.
Ok, Carbon plus Iodine equals... I don't know! How am I supposed to know!?
Blue plus yellow equals green... AH! What is this??
Residential, C plus I equals question. How does that equal words??
Loading? Ok... residential? WHY!?
Ooohhhh... commercial plus industrial... yay! I'm gonna lose my mind!
Oh god it's a... I didn't... What? What did I do? What happened? Huh??
What happened!? It just blew up and took care of it... I think.
Lol 69 dot. I don't know, what do you want from me? What?
Don't tell me I have like to click this 69 times... If you do... I will be VERY upset.
Can you... you son of a bitch! You are a son of a bitch!
How am I supposed to play Pac-Man? Pac-Frank... I'm not good at Pac-Frank/Man.
Oh god no! Get away from me! Where are my big power-ups? I don't have any power-ups.
They're gonna corner me. They're SO gonna corner me. Oh get out of here!
Get out of here, get out of here! I'm not gonna... Oh no you don't! No you don't!
strange noises Oh no! Blue! Blue, you son of a bitch! I'm not good at Pac-Man!
Let's play the Feud! OK, here we go. Oh god no! Not off the bat!
AH! Not off the bat!! Get outta here! No! No!
AH! Oh it's a nightmare! Oh it's a nightmare. You get outta here!
You get outta here, you boosh, you boosh, you boosh, you boosh! No!!
Oh! Why?? Why did that happen? I don't know, but I don't care.
I'm okay, I'm okay... I'm just, I'm okay.
Oh my god! I'm okay! AHHH! OH! HOW!? Ah no!!
You son of a bitch! Oh good for you! Good thing you give multiple lives or else I would be very...
How is this fair?? They're fast! AH they're fast! Oh FUDGE YOU!
I hate you! I hate you! NOO!! AH! I hate, I hate!
I hate... no get away from me! AH god...
I just noticed that there was a big 5 that popped up. I realized it was probably important, so I'm gonna write it down.
Ok, ok, ok, ok, ok... alright, alright, alright!
Fudge! Alright, alright alright! AH!! Why is this working?
Why did that work? Ahhh.. I'm never gonna beat you! I'm bad at Pac-Man!
Oh crepe... crepe, crepe, French, French... I'm turning French again! I'm turning freakin' French!
I'm just gonna run these guys in a circle. Or they're gonna catch me! AH they're gonna catch me!
OH they're gonna catch me!! Piss, balls, ass! Piss, balls and... FUCK!
It's just so much... No! Get away! NO you red bastard!! You red fuck! You red fuck!
made up words AH! I am dead! I am going to die. AH! I hate everything! You red fuuuuudge!!
It's boner-ific! Bonerf-tastic! lots of screaming Piss, balls, ass, fuck! AH!
I can't make it, 'cause I just, I did wrong. I did wrong! I did wrong!
I did wrong... NO!! AH!
Oh get away from me! Oh crap, oh crap, oh crap! chicken noises
Fudgesicles! strange noises I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead!!
No! Yeah! No! Yeah! No! Fudge.
No! No no no no no no no no! YEAH!!!
I overloaded my mic so much there it's not even funny. But I don't care, I don't care, I don't care!
I did it! I think I won. Can I stop now? Only 20 questions in... AH...
I don't know... I don't wanna know... What do I do?
7. Is that important too? I'll write it down... 7.
Which country produces the finest plumbers in the world? Mario! Italy...
Here we go... oh Duck Hunt? Oh, ok! ok! ok, ok, oh I almost missed that one.
No I got him. I'll shoot you in the face! NOO!! Mother of Gaaahhhh!
No no no no! I said no! Oh yeah! Yeah baby, first try!
That means I have all 5 of my lives, but apparently I'm gonna lose them anyway.
Get 'em all... I don't think I hit them all. Oh there was one sneaking down there.
Oh I got him... did I get him? Shoot you in the... NO! What? What did I press?? I didn't know!
How many letters in settlers? I don't know! What did I do? I don't know what I did!
Can you tell me what I did because I don't know what I did, and I want to know what I did!
Ok, you're a trick question, you bastard! My brain is in regular mode.
How many letters in settlers? Settlers is an anogram of letters... Yeah, yeah, there's "letters" in settlers, so there's 1.
OH!! 10 plus 10 is 20... unless it's not. That's binary down there. Are you talking addition in binary?
Because that would be, uh, 1-0-0. That would be 1-0-0 in binary. Yay!
That's a pretty sheep, but what the hell do I do? What do I do??
Ah, what do I do!? You're not telling me what I do! Uh, uh, BAH! Ah, ffff...
What did I click? I think I clicked this...
What is the name of Chapter 3 of the Impossible Quiz Book? How am I supposed to know that? Was that in the beginning?
I think I clicked this. I did, ok. BAH! BAH! Ba-
What did I press? I think I typed "bah" Search for the evil being.
No! No! Why are you doing this to me?? No! Save me! NO! WHY!?
I've spent so much time back-tracking... grunts Loading...
I don't know what the evil being is! Evil, evil, evil, evil! Evil... evil.. EVIL!
There's evil in... NO!! Wait what? No, stop it! Goddammit!! AHH!!
grunts Loading... Save us! Ok, I'll save you! You're a bunch of asses! Fuck you, god FUCK!
No! Stop it! Stop it, stop it, stop it, stop it! Hey hey, stop it! Stop it, you're an ass!
Which epic sword do you need to defeat Yoglett Salmon? I don't know!
Uh... Ah that's a trick, you're not real. You're not real!
An exception of 79 has occurred... yoglett.exe. Ha ha ha! I'm waiting!
Oh, oh, oh wait a minute! OH! Who's the man now!?
What do I do? Oh god, another game. Arrow keys to move up, arrow to jump, 'r' to asplode.
Why would I want to asplode?? Here we go!
Where am I? Oh, I'm over here. What is... what is the point of this?
What is the point of this? Oh goddammit. Ah, oh fuck! Oh I jump on their heads, ok.
strange noises Ah, oh, no! fffff.... No no no! Boing, boing bitch! Fuck you.
You're gonna come here and you're gonna be... boing! Bitch!
Oh no! Can I make that jump? ffffff... I AM DONE! NO MORE! NO MORE!
I've been playing this for an hour... NO MORE! I GIVE UP! I QUIT! IT'S AWFUL, I HATE IT!
I HATE IT SO MUCH, I WANNA DIE!!!
So anyway, that was the Impossible Quiz Book: Chapter 2.
I saw it all the way to the end and got the amazing ending. Wasn't that fun and fantastic!?
Hahaha... so if you enjoyed me getting very angry and now very happy 'cause I'm happy and sunshine and rainbows everywhere...
Let me know in the comments below and leave a like for my suffering.
And as always, I will see you in the next video! Bye-bye!